join the CinemaSins team in Nashville
for sin week 2023 every year we release
extra videos for our sin club members
and hold live panels with our friends
and fans in person tickets to sin week
are available at a discounted rate for
the month of December space is limited
so head to cinemasins.com cineweek to
reserve your spot today the link is in
the description
[Music]
thank you
all of this rock phlebotomy got
immediately more interesting once I
found out this was an overcomplicated
family tree but now that I'm actually
interested the whole thing moves so fast
that it's damn near impossible to get a
glimpse of what it all means plus since
we're dealing with the targaryens
shouldn't the blood be flowing uphill
occasionally
not content with long ponderous shots of
people walking Hot D has now removed the
walking and will just be long ponderous
shots of empty rooms
[Music]
but also Ramin tajwadi's music continues
to be an inspiration throughout the
entire series no matter the scene he
always knows how to set the mood take
your sin off damn it and we're back to
some walking a full 30 seconds of this
boy walking in fact are we sure this was
based on Fire and Blood and not George
RR Martin's lesser-known blood in cardio
quietly in the background for multiple
episodes Talia has been a character with
few words so revealing that she's also
had a lot of influence in this world is
cool and introduces the idea the
background characters could be more than
just extras but when that extra is also
a producer the surprise is not as
surprising as you might think
[Music]
playing with your balls on the small
council meeting table wait until you're
alone to do that trust me if your
co-workers find out your balls have been
on the table it's a whole thing or so
I've heard what is it that could not
have waited an hour Thailand Lannister
does he really think an urgent summons
to a small council meeting would be over
something insignificant you knew the
King was unwell and ready to die any day
this is the most read the room situation
to ever have a room ready to be read
aren't the Lannister supposed to be
smart and cunning there's two sins for
not being Tywin I miss him so much we
grieve for viserys the peaceful viserys
the peaceful did he pick that name out
himself this is almost as bad as bran
the broken I said almost then we may
proceed now with the full Assurance of
his Blessing on our long laid plans
immediately admitting you had long laid
secret plans in the room with the person
who's back you were plotting behind
Thailand not only remains a [ __ ] but
this over explaining for narrative's
sake is an insult to Allison and the
audience I'm sorry but I'm really hung
up on these balls are they supposed to
serve as proof that the person you see
in the room is actually in the room is
the council not in session or something
until all the balls are in their sockets
both of those would be fine I suppose
but if that's the case then these things
are just a formality and I can't see why
this group that's been planning to usurp
the throne gives a [ __ ] about these
balls now the viserys is dead why is the
show smashing us upside the head with
these things 20 years ago most of them
now dead I'm glad someone's keeping
track of the chronology through all
these time skips the old gods in the new
all understood I wasn't and I will not
believe that he said this on his death
bed alone with only the boy's mother
Islanders have witnessed barely someone
on the small council is making logical
sense I look forward to hearing more
wisdom from Lord beesberry as the show
continues well
all right here we go sir Kristen Cole
about to finally face some consequences
and damn it when is this man going to
pay What's it gonna take for him to get
to the find out part after [ __ ]
around so much here's two cents for
letting this [ __ ] get away with
murder while not having enough Charisma
to justify it but he has four daughters
all of them unmarried further relegating
the role of women to be nothing but
political bargaining chips in a scheme
for power you may say that's just how
the world was back then surely you can't
send the show for an imperfect system
that was limited by the times right and
we'll remind you that this is TV since
where we can induce sin whatever we want
stick around we have a cool clown that
makes shadow puppets on Tuesdays as Lord
beesberry's head lays cracked open on
his power Stone it should now be obvious
to everyone in the room that you can
have your balls and you can have your
sir Kristen but you cannot have both one
more word and I'll have you removed from
this chamber and sent to the wall oh
good to know the Night's Watch still
exists I was starting to get worried you
forgot about them you know a show is
getting claustrophobic when I'm begging
for more of the wall sir Harold detaches
his cloak so easily he's left Edna Mode
asking why didn't I think of that I
recognize No Authority but the Kings and
until there is one I have no place here
show upholds long tradition of creating
a character we might dare like just to
have them written out of the episode if
one possesses the thing the other will
take it away yes princess Helena's
prophecies are an interesting and
mystical addition to the show but
weirdly we know that their prophecies
but none of the characters seem to have
caught on the way everyone treats her it
seems like she's been saying strange
things all the time for decades now so
aside from plot points she has to be
giving people a heads up on things like
burnt tongues stubbed toes and the
gastroenterological effects of their
beam consumption just saying no one One
Ever Knows the soup is too hot there is
a beast beneath the boards Helena's
prophecies May often come true but I'm
just not sure what predicting Shaq's
entrance to the NBA has to do with this
show find him thus Begins the pointless
race between Allison and Otto to
accomplish basically the same goal
here's three sins for finding yet
another way to waste our time the
lightness of this shot makes the
darkness of this shot only possible if
Raines opening this window somehow just
brought balance to the force also giving
the queen Who Never Was A Room With a
View entering the Queen's Chambers
without knocking or announcing yourself
this isn't your Castle Kristen have some
respect for boundaries here's five cents
just for being you he's had time to get
it wet the same thing I said to my
younger brother the first time we set up
the slip and slide in the yard somehow
makes it into the episode you'll not
leave this room without declaring your
intention in bed gotcha good Otto I'm
sorry this is probably the best episode
they've had all season but I've just
been so bored by all the others leading
up to this that I'm finding it hard to
care about anything that's going on how
exactly does Scary Larry always have
such great seats to every single
important moment in King's Landing does
he have a special code at StubHub and by
StubHub I of course mean the local
ticketing agency run by all the citizens
that got caught stealing by the
kingsguard
one of many I'd wager ah yes the Old
King Robert strategy maybe one of them
will grow up to be an underutilized plot
device could he be any more obvious
about sneaking out for Pete's sake man
use the back exit or something no wonder
you got caught [ __ ] Lord Caswell he
tolerated the princess but years because
it was my surround Duty Eric based on
the carbon dating of viserys's corpse
this show has been going on for like 2
000 years and in all that time the
writers couldn't show us Sir Eric
tolerating the prince's proclivities so
now we have to sit through discount
Errol Flynn and discount our role Flynn
arguing the exposition onto the screen
wherever you're going then with such
urgency come on man you were clever
enough to engage in some subterfuge in
the throne room but now you can't even
attempt to lie to save your own life
your wife is sick Your Castle was raided
by Bandits they just opened a
Whataburger back home anything will do
you spent many hours with the queen of
late Otto brings this up to Laris
because he thinks something is afoot in
the meetings with Allison have aroused
suspicions which is all well and good
but it doesn't make this line there's no
reason those hours could not in the end
but benefit you any less [ __ ] up when
we learn more about those hours later in
the episode The Silent sisters seem
really cool I can't wait to dive into
their lore and learn more about them I'm
sure the show won't let such interesting
characters go unexplored Alice's display
of emotion during her final moments with
the body of viserys presents an
interesting complexity it's almost like
these two shared more than arguments
over heirs betrothals and successions
but if thou were true I'm sure we would
have seen it on screen right my serious
regrets for the lack of ceremony in bed
I got you good Allison I'm sorry again
this is a really good scene and I love
seeing these two go Toe to Toe but it's
pretty absurd that much of this
conversation hasn't already occurred
between the two of them I mean for a
while now viserys has been knocking on
heaven's door so there was no need for
all this patience
no Allison if you want to apply to join
our team of pointing out the obvious
we'll happily send you a raven without
your dragon she may be persuaded to
negotiate let's check the math on that
one suppose you take mayles off the
table runner still has cyrex Damon has
caraxis Bayla has Moon Dancer Lenor left
sea smoke behind jacera says ver Max
luceris has air ax and Joffrey has
terraxis that's seven dragons meanwhile
Allison each of your three children has
one now we typically let cine handle the
math but I'm pretty sure 7 is still
bigger than three let's take a moment to
talk about these disguises not since
Jennifer of wengerberg wore a hood over
her head have we seen such shoddy
disguises y'all make Clark Kent's
disguise look well planned Cole and
aemon have it up on this secret meeting
which is a massive stroke of luck wait a
second a meeting like this out in the
open for all to see well that is just a
plot convenient misstep on the part of
Otto in the white worm almost like
they're not two of the smartest
characters in the whole show my
condolence is underpassing of your team
all right I can't deny that it's awesome
how the writers brought back masaria as
an unexpected power broker with some
serious sway over Hulu inherit the crown
and reveals how the whole insulated
world of kings and queens is still very
much connected and influenced by The
World At Large something that's been
missing from the show up to this point
at best Secrets him somewhere safe title
of my sex tape I could have killed him
as easily as it was fun fruit have you
ever tried to kill a wasp those numbers
are fast and mean there's a reason the
cans of spray they make to kill them
shoot up to 30 feet so the sin here is
for wasps and you're underestimating of
those little stabby hellions there is no
power but what the people allow you to
take yeah this discount Peter Baelish
knowledge's power scene really loses its
punch when you realize all their
leverage goes out the door the moment
aegon is found then we'll see who
becomes a wasp on fruit or some other
cool metaphor that makes me sound smart
sorry hit aegon under the candle table
in the sept in episode 4 when Damon was
half in the back he got a private room
and a bed and some morning Go Juice I'd
be remiss if I didn't call out the
waning standards of the white worms
Hospitality also speaking of early
season Damon whatever happened to the
Damon his impotent storyline is that
just never gonna come up again why won't
you finish what you started seriously it
can't be that hard swords tackling
tickling excitement let me go we'll find
a ship and sail away never to be found
sorry aegon only one character gets to
escape secretly by boat and we already
gave that pass to Lenor also if you
wanted to flea by ship you haven't done
that by now viserys has been dying for
like 50 000 years shortly in all that
time you could have found that secret
cave everyone in Game of Thrones knew
about and frequented well played
I know this is a game yes it is it's a
Game of Thrones or did you forget which
prequel you were in there's no better
word for the last 20 minutes this
episode wasted other than a game a
pointless dull game that was the worst
edition of hide and seek I've ever seen
and I once watched some of my college
roommates get drunk and then try to
stuff there oh you his daughter's
childhood companion Christian Cole be
named Lord commander of the king's God
if you want to promote someone with a
proclivity for killing innocence that's
up to you but at least do it at a time
when it makes sense as opposed to
bringing it up as a non-sequitur in a
conversation that had everything to do
with your relationship with your father
and nothing to do with the kingsguard
you look so much like your mother in
certain lights oh
oh what is this the most photogenic cane
in the world we get it this means
something it's not beating us over the
head with it and use it on one of the
characters we hate preferably sir
Kristen show doesn't clarify that the
being in defeat part isn't what's wrong
with this scene it's the uncomfortable
way Laris goes about getting the feet
that makes him the heel and queen dies
the bees fly without purpose actually if
Queen dies The Beehive Works quickly to
replace her usually after a month or so
science is meat
doing he's whittling on a piece of wood
beating your meat to the Queen's feet
till you eat your skate in your
um pantaloons chewing with your mouth
open I see we've graduated from walking
and moved on to dramatic eating dramatic
standing dramatic sitting more dramatic
standing and dramatic doing that thing
when you're sitting high up in a bed
against the headboard with me Princess
renice doesn't question exactly who you
are seriously I have no idea if this is
Eric or Eric and that detail has become
a contributing factor to suspense that
I'm not sure the writers created
intentionally oh good another excellent
disguise are the cloaks and Westeros
magical so they keep your identity
secret did I miss that part in the books
just kidding I didn't read the books
literacy oh no not that building okay I
have no idea where this fire is or why
it matters I believe the show wants us
to think this is messaria's house maybe
it is maybe it isn't no one cares about
that right now but this shadowy figure
does make me question how the criminals
lyrics enlisted as his foot soldiers
we're not good enough to previously
evade capture by the city watch but are
now all ninjas straight from the League
of Shadows Lara says foot soldiers
renice and
um Rick run into traffic because without
proper motivation they need these extras
to push these characters in The
Direction the Story needed them to go
because he didn't like me thinking that
naming your air is about picking your
favorite it's not about favorites aegon
if it were he'd have named his model of
King's Landing as his Heir we all saw
how he looked at it
answering a yes or no question with an
assessment of intelligence our beloved
King viserys the peaceful is dead show
doesn't acknowledge that the confusion
in the crowd is due to the fact that no
one thought he was alive to begin with
royal skip oh wait sorry force a habit
oh well too late now on to the next
scene cool entrance bro but this still
seems a bit dangerous knowing aegon he's
just as likely to troll them by taking a
step backward and taking a blade to the
skull and the sin of course is that this
doesn't happen for all of Allison's talk
earlier about how important it was to
keep rhaenice's Dragon she sure made
zero effort to secure the dragon pit
show takes this long long to realize
what I actually meant when I said that I
wanted to see a crowning scene
[Applause]
homelander did this scene better
wow I have to say this is a really
exciting way to take the interesting
suspense thriller of an episode you
managed to pull off and turn it into a
big question about how few rainies gives
about the citizens of the realm also
cool entrance bro but I have a few notes
first how were you not smooshed to death
when your dragon came through the
ceiling where did you get that neat
armor was your dragon holding it for you
and finally why not just escape from the
dragon pit through another exit you
clearly didn't come up here to kill the
high Towers in doing so put your life at
risk this move looks all of the cool but
makes none of the sense
if Auto Hightower ends up being named
odor because he can only say odor for
the rest of his life I will give back
every single sin
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa okay that was cool but also
anti-climactic
a monster under every bed plotto no the
king changed his mind
you are being a cheered Tater torrent
and a pain in my ass
nutcase
require hear us to his whereabouts and
describe him
he's my best friend he's my pal he's my
homeboy my rotten Soldier he's my sweet
cheese my good time boy anyone else
anyone anyone
smoking weed as you wish that day she
was amazed to discover that when he was
saying As You Wish what he meant was I
love you he whispered his final wish
that his first born son aegon
[Music]
should [ __ ] off